jet is officially nerfed
or is she in case you're living under a
rock riot officially announced jet's
nerf last week adjusting her tail wind
ability riot added another layer of
complexity to the agent adding a step
before player can use her dash and a
player can only use it within a
12-second window but is it really a nerf
what do the pros think
that's not bad at all okay this is me
trying to do it mac speed that barely
does anything the op part of jet was
that you could play any off angle and
you didn't have to risk anything and you
didn't have to think about much i think
that we'll just pick other doulas more
honestly it's only that bad in my
opinion
i think uh chambers is just gonna be
really annoying to play against so
chambers like really good already the
nerf isn't that big it's actually it's
pretty big it's pretty big it's the end
of an era you know the end of the jet
you can't spam it after you tap it
there's like a 0.6 second cooldown
definitely a big nerf a creative one as
well so it's cool i think it'll be
interesting